hello everyone and welcome to round 11
of the very strong 1936 international
tournament in Moscow we have any Cola in
club which women vs jose role kappa
blanka now as you've seen in my I
believe it's a game from round 3
capablanca started with two draws and
then he got a win against the nickel I
remain in round three but it wasn't like
the the greatest of wins or you mean
just blundered his Queen so it was a
basically capablanca started with a win
in this tournament by his opponent
blundering a queen but now it's time for
a different different game human now has
the white pieces and kappa blanka will
have to prove that he is indeed the
better player here and as you remember
in that video i also mentioned that in
the night 1935 international tournament
in moscow
nikolai illumine defeated Capablanca in
the first round which most likely costed
him first place in that tournament
so before we check out the game we do
have a nice photo challenge and it's
this photo challenge will be a bit
different but I still do hope you
enjoyed so it's a two-fold question who
is the Grandmaster on the left in this
photo and part two of the question
- you know what's what's the story
behind the photo so best of luck to
everyone let's check out the game like
we said everyone has the white pieces
and he opens with Knight to f3 the reti
opening d5 we have c4 c6 we have III and
the Knight to f6 are transposing into
the English Knight to c3 Knight bTW 7c
captures on d5 seek after sandy 5 and d4
now we have east 6 Bishop to d3 Bishop
to d6 castles castles and here White has
a variety of options white should
definitely simply continue developing
pieces Bishop to d2 is all right Queen
c2 is fine any ideas a rocky one a3 but
here a human goes for the forcing efore
and this is basically you know making it
too easy for for a cup of lanka to to
play this game
couple Blanca has the black pieces and
this move simply lost Capablanca to
exchange a couple of pieces and
you know simplified the position which
definitely goes in his favor as he is
considered to be the better the better
player and of course he does have the
black pieces so you know it's basically
a free equalize so that's something that
often happens when you when you play
against someone who you think is a
better player than you you're not gonna
play something you would normally play a
rather you think okay I'm not strong
enough to go for a win here I'm just
gonna go for a draw and then you're
gonna lose that game because if that
person is in is in fact better than you
then you know he's gonna beat you
regardless of the equal position so we
have d captures only four backup of
Blanca Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 Bishop captures on e4 and
now Knight to f6 bringing the Knights to
a nice active square forcing the bishop
to move back Bishop to c2 and now
h6 so okay those two the bishop pair is
very nice I think that King but you know
there's a there's a long way from making
something happen with that Queen e2 we
have the b6 now kappa blanka is ready to
develop the LightSquared Bishop Knight
to e5 and now Bishop to be 7 this is
move 14 and black already developed his
a light square bishop without having to
really work for it so if if you if you
see that when black develops his light
square bishop without you know having to
concede it somewhere it's it's a very
nice game for black rook to d1 and now
comes Luke to c8 brush up to f4 you have
to get the other room rook into the game
as well bishop to be eight and now
Bishop back to b3 Queen to e7
we have rook a to c1 now the other look
is developed as well and now comes
Knight to d5
we have rook captures on c8 root
chapters on c8 and now Bishop to g3 and
here kappa blanka has to figure out how
to continue how to continue here his
position is definitely nice he has a
very nice control of the C file but that
could very easily change if white for
example goes Queen d2 and then brings
his own rope to c1
so here a couple Blanca plays a queen to
g5 which increases the activity of the
queen but
also keeps an eye on that see one square
but but what kappa blanka really wants
to do is force a queen trade here and
and go for the endgame here the best
idea for white is to play queen of three
attack the f7 pawn and here you would a
couple monk would either have to admit
that maybe Queen to g5 was a bit too too
active and go back with the Queen or
give up give up the bishop pair via my
Bishop captures on e5 so this would have
been the best idea for white but here
you mean again played Queen to d2 now
going straight into capo Blancas
territory so couple on guys of course
we're very happy about this Queen
captures rook captures and now rook to
c1 Bishop to d1 you don't really want to
play something like that then this rook
will stay active for the entire game and
you'll be stuck with the bishop on d1 so
you do have to play Ruby one cup of
Blanca exchanges the rooks rook captures
the bishop captures and the now comes f6
kicking away tonight we have 9th to d3
and now Bishop captures ng three pawn
captures and g3 and now if you look at
this position which this position is
basically the result of that Queen d2
move of offering a queen trade by Roman
now you can see that Capablanca has to
pawn islands and rumen has three point
islands so definitely better for black
and at the other hand white also has a
double the G pawn so that's also not
working really well for him and the
capablanca has an easier way of
activating his King so a small you know
advantages but still advantages King to
f7 couple Blanca brings the King into
the game
nice to see one and now Knight to e7
Bishop to b3
we have h5 now 92 v2 and now Knight to
f5 notice that the isolated pawn is on a
dark square which doesn't really work in
White's favor as the white has a light
square bishop so the only way for you to
ever protect this point is to either
somehow managed to bring the King over
to defend it or the knight will be stuck
in defending it forever
we have Bishop to c2 trying to grab the
knight as you know if you if you
eliminate the night then couple Blancas
light square bishop
I will also be kind of useless against
the isolated the deep on that is on a
dark square so 936 of course Capablanca
doesn't fall out this exchange nice to
f4 going for the h5 pawn and here the
IDF for square is very active for the
night so what I want you to do here is
pause the video and try to find a move
capablanca place to really to really
improve his position it's a very nice
move the engine really agrees with
capablanca so you know it's not some
it's not some tactic to solve just you
know to get an idea how to proceed in a
situation like this so feel free to
check it out I will give it a couple of
seconds for you to decide for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those who if you
just wanna enjoy the show here
capablanca played g5 g5 is a very nice
idea because you do have to move the
knight your knight is attacked on f4 if
you play Knight to d3 then after an IED
b5 there's no way for you to defend the
d4 point so this immediately loses upon
another thing after after this g5 now
you can play 92 and you know from e2
Knight will protect the pawn here but
then your knight is stuck forever I need
to guarding this d4 pawn so what your
diamond played was actually Knight
captures on h5 and here kappa blanka
could have really really gone for some
activity but instead he went for Knights
to b5 to grab the d4 pawn immediately
but there is also a very nice line here
Bishop to d5 first attack the a to pawn
and after white figures out how to
defend this either Bishop to be one or a
three bishop to be one then comes f5
because the only way white can ever get
his knight back into the game is to push
g4 and then bring his knight over to g3
but after white pushes g4 of course
black will not capture black will play
f4 and then this Knight is stuck here
for the rest of the game there is no way
he's ever coming back into the game so
this would have been a very nice idea
but Kappa Monica's idea also works so
after this night to h5 move
we have Knight to b5 going for the pawn
now comes g4 of course making room for
the night and g3 night cap
son before grabbing a pawn we have
bishop moves and now comes Bishop to d5
attacking da to pawn now you can't
really defend it anymore that's why
after this a knight capture Sundy for a
better idea was a bishop to be one
simply keeping an eye on the a to pawn
here this seems like a more logical move
you know as you all know the
relationship between the knight and the
bishop when they are apart with two
squares in between them then the knight
the bishop controls all of the squares
the knight can use in front of him and
of course the knight controls the bishop
as well so this seems like a more
logical move but in fact in this
position it doesn't work bishop to d5
attacking the pawn a3 now the only way
to defend the pawn and now Bishop to b3
forcing a trade of bishops now you can
see that it's actually night that's
controlling the Bishop Bishop captures
Knight captures and now we have night 2
G 3 human tries to get the knight back
into the game and now comes Knights to
d2 controlling the Knights jump to e4
and also preparing Knight to c4 if you
allow Knights the c4 then you will
either lose the B to pawn or if the B to
pawn moves you'll lose the a3 pawn so
not much you can do about this before
it's played not allowing Knights the c-4
to come with such a threat but now comes
b5 simply keeping an eye on that pawn on
a three-night b1 will now attack it 92
we have nice to be 1 attacking the pawn
and now comes Knights to d4 now if you
kind of don't want to play a 6 here if
you play a 6 here simply defending the
pawn with ideas of capturing it later
white can simply play it in night c2 to
defend the pawn or even Knight to b3 so
now if black captures 95 will grab the
a6 pawn Knight attacks Knight captures
also defending the b4 pawn this wouldn't
be so great for a couple Monica
so after Knight to d4 he decided to
immediately capture Knight captures on
a3
and now comes Knight here attacking the
a7 pawn and now comes Capablanca main
idea again you're a 7 point is under
attack
how do you defend it pause the video
here and try to find capablanca idea of
course I will get a couple of seconds
for you to decide if you
interested in doing it so once again for
those of you who were able to do it I
applaud you you are an excellent endgame
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
King te8 is the move Capablanca played
and now it becomes obvious Knight
captures an a7 is met with King 37 and
there is there are no squares which
would allow this Knights to get back
into the game the knight is trapped King
c7 King b7 King captures on a7 is coming
or white would simply give up the night
for a pawn and lose the game so here you
mean so that after King e8 was played he
decided to play g3 now comes King to d7
attacking the knight Knights the be a
check of course you can't grab the a7
pawn and now we have King to d5
f4 was played and here after knife - C -
this is move move 44 Nicholai Nicholai
Sherman resigned the game why did you
resign well it's fairly obvious the
knight is attacking the before pawn
after your attack after you defend it
with 92-86 you have a knight on a6 that
that's that alone is reason enough for
you to resign about after King defile
you see that white has no no good plan
against King c4 and capturing the pawn
whatever you do try to bring the King in
simply attack the pawn king goes Knight
captures and now if you exchange Knights
then the deponent game is of course
winning for black and if you try
anything black will simply ignore you
push a 5 and you know you're welcome to
do whatever you want on the King side
the a4 point is simply too fast so yeah
after night to see to are you resigned
the game and again a very nice victory
to wins against Truman in this
tournament for kappa blanka so
definitely he got his revenge for last
year so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marco
Sanchez
Alex menara and Chakrapani and big el
the crusher for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot - really appreciate
it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you all